herzlich willkommen das ist zdf heute
live eine lange und intensive nacht
könnte das für bundesverkehrsminister
andreas scheuer werden zumindest geht
davon derjenige aus der den pkw maut
untersuchungs ausschuss vorsitzt und
dieser untersuchungsausschuss tagt schon
seit heute morgen und er tagt immer noch
wie wir hier sehen
und er tat wahrscheinlich bis tief in
die nacht hinein berlin
marie-elisabeth-lüders-haus
anhörungssaal 3.101 da brennt noch licht
denn es sind viele fragen zu klären
andreas scheuer ist der fünfte von
insgesamt fünf zeugen die befragt werden
dort was dabei herauskommt damit
beschäftigen wir uns heute abend wie
immer eure fragen in die kommentare und
wenn ihr uns über die zdf heute app
guckt dann auch gerne die fragen an
diese adresse hier unten
unsere hauptstadt korrespondent in
schackenthal abonji ist heute abend bei
uns um das aufzuarbeiten was da passiert
bzw
du bist nicht bei uns ja container
sondern du bist natürlich vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss was genau
passiert denn da gerade
ja genau wir haben hier jetzt gerade
eine unterbrechung das ist ja alles
tatsächlich so ein bisschen wie ein
krimi die erst der erste teil ist jetzt
schon vorbei da wurden die ersten drei
zeugen gehört das waren die vertreter
der betreiberfirma und jetzt gab es eine
unterbrechung natürlich zum einen um die
medien zu unterrichten und zum anderen
aber auch weil die fdp eine beratungs
unterbrechung beantragt hat es soll
eigentlich jetzt in den nächsten minuten
weitergehen mit dem zweiten teil in dem
dann diejenigen zu wort kommen die
sozusagen auf seite von andreas scheuer
stehen muss ich das präzisieren sind
nicht mehrere sondern der nächste zeuge
ist ein ehemaliger staatssekretär der
bei den umstrittenen gesprächen dabei
gewesen ist und dann soll eben heute
noch andreas scheuer vernommen werden
das ist momentan der aktuelle stand der
dinge
wie hat man sich das vorzustellen sitzt
andreas scheuer jetzt in der cafeteria
und wartet darauf dass ihm jemand sagt
so jetzt geht's los oder wo ist er
gerade wie hat man sich das vorzustellen
also ich kann nicht ganz genau sagen wo
ist hier haben wir eben noch nicht
gesehen ich gehe auch nicht davon aus
dass er hier im gebäude in irgendeinem
raum sitzt die wege hier in berlin die
sind ja nicht weit und es gibt einen
zeitplan für diesen
untersuchungsausschuss hier
er wurde heute morgen ein bisschen
gerissen das ganze sollte um 10.30
losgehen dann ging es erst eine gute
stunde später los dann braucht man für
den ersten zeugen bei der befragung vier
stunden mehr als vier stunden
das war schon eine ganze menge da kamen
hier schon unruhe auf auch unter den
mitgliedern des untersuchungsausschusses
dabei fürchteten schon einige das ganze
würde sich so in die länge ziehen dass
man andreas scheuer gar nicht mal laden
könnte aber wir haben jetzt hier gesehen
dass die weiteren zeugenbefragungen sehr
zügig vorangegangen sind das auch immer
wieder mitglieder gesagt haben ja ich
muss jetzt mal auf die uhr gucken ich
mich mit meiner frage ich habe den
zeitplan im blick also alles deutet
darauf hin dass man sich jetzt ungefähr
wieder dem ursprünglichen zeitplan
annähern möchte und das würde also auch
bedeuten dass andreas scheuer egal wo er
ist nur vorwarnung bekommen kann wenn
sich abzeichnet dass sein
vorangehen der vorangehende zeuge so
langsam zum ende kommt mit seiner
aussage und dann wird er sicherlich noch
zeit haben schnell hier her zu kommen
eine userin schreibt über youtube was
soll diese frage ob scheuer gelogen hat
die ganze zeit wir kennen doch längst
die antwort also diese userin hat die
antwort für sich offenbar schon gefunden
der untersuchungsausschuss sucht sie
noch und im kern geht es und das wollen
wir uns gemeinsam mal anschauen
tatsächlich auch um die frage ob steuer
das parlament belogen hat es geht um
eine situation am 25 09 2009 10 war
scheuer im parlament vom fdp
abgeordneten oliver luksic ganz konkret
zu einer sache befragt worden
gab es das angebot der betreiber den
vertrag erst nach dem urteil zu
unterschreiben und wenn es das gab warum
haben sie es abgelehnt sie eine - war
nicht thema in dem gespräch am 22
november tja also auch um diese
situation geht es runter nach dem was da
über den tag über heute ausgesagt wurde
wie sehr steht shia denn jetzt unter
druck
ja was diese frage an betrifft steht
extrem unter druck allerdings kommt auch
ein bisschen darauf an wen man fragt wir
haben jetzt gerade diese unterbrechung
hier gehabt wir hatten drei
zeugenaussagen von diesen betreibern es
geht ja im grunde genommen
vor allem um ein gespräch am 29 november
2008 10
darin so sagen dass hier die drei zeugen
die heute gehört worden sind hätten sie
die betreiber angeboten dass man den
vertrag auch erst nach dem urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofes unterschreibt
und dann wäre das risiko geringer
gewesen dass zum beispiel der bund jetzt
auch schaden schadenersatz leisten muss
und da ist jetzt eben die frage haben
die betreiber recht sagen die betreiber
die wahrheit oder hat andreas scheuer im
bundestag die wahrheit gesagt als er
sagte dass das angebot habe es nie
gegeben wir haben hier gerade eben die
vertreter der verschiedenen parteien
gehört die der unionsvertreter kam raus
und hat sehr deutlich zweifel an der
glaubwürdigkeit dieses zeugen geäußert
er sagt naja das seien 23 zeugen gewesen
die gehörten aber gemeinsam zu einem
bieterkonsortium sein also eigentlich
nur als eine gruppe zu werten und jetzt
käme es eben darauf an die andere seite
zu hören das sind der staatssekretär der
ehemalige staatssekretär von andreas
scheuer und andreas scheuer selbst dann
kam die spd also koalitionspartner und
hat gesagt die zeugen seien doch sehr
glaubwürdig gewesen aber am ende sei die
frage ob der nächste zeuge auch
glaubwürdig sagen könnte dass es dieses
angebot nicht gegeben habe und dann
stünde hier aussage gegen aussage das
leider in einen part und dann gibt es
natürlich noch die opposition die hier
raus gekommen ist und gesagt hat also
glasklare sache nach diesen drei
zeugenaussagen hat andreas scheuer den
bundestag belogen da kann er eigentlich
nicht im amt bleiben und die fdp hat
gerade eben sogar angekündigt wenn sich
heute eine patt situation ergeben sollte
und union und spd gemeinsam
naja auf der grundlage können wir hier
nicht entscheiden was die wahrheit ist
dann würde sie ein sogenanntes
kreuzverhör beantragen dann gäbe es
irgendwann eine sitzung des
untersuchungsausschusses in der alle
zeugen gleichzeitig vernommen werden und
sich auch in die augen schauen müssen
und dann geschaut wird wer ist am
glaubwürdigsten oder nicht das würde die
fdp zumindest beantragen ob sein so
kommt ist noch mal eine andere frage
das stichwort politkrimi hast du gerade
schon genannt das scheint ja immer
zutreffen dazu werden wenn es das nicht
sowieso schon war
also wenn man sich die user kommentare
anguckt dann sind sich die leute so
ziemlich alle einig ja andreas scheuer
hat gelogen
zum beispiel schreibt minister davorka
1995 auf youtube kurz gesagt die antwort
hat euer gelogen ja und die lange
version ist auch ja also die community
ist sich einig der
untersuchungsausschuss noch nicht ganz
hast du gerade gesagt stark unterlage
lassen den tag x bis zu diesem zeitpunkt
revue passieren
es wird hitzig im out
untersuchungsausschuss und immer mehr
zum fernduell zwischen der ehemaligen
betreiberfirma und minister scheuer
klaus peter schulenberg gesellschafter
der maut firma auto ticket bestätigt
heute dass er persönlich dem minister
angeboten habe den vertragsabschluss zu
verschieben nach dem urteil des bgh
unser treffen berichtet wir haben
software entwickeln in infrastruktur
investiert und wir sind für dieses
debakel hielten nicht verantwortlich der
frust sitzt tief bei der maut firma und
die aussagen belasten minister schwer
vor einem jahr hatte er noch behauptet
dass ein angebot zur verschiebung nie
vorgelegen habe zwar nicht thema in dem
gespräch am 22 november
für die opposition ist nach den ersten
beiden zeugen die sachlage klar man kann
jetzt nach dem zweiten zeugen sehr gut
sehen dass der zweite zeuge komplett den
minister und auch die csu versenkt hat
für mich ist es klar dass der minister
am 25 september 2009 10 nicht die
wahrheit im parlament gesagt hat schon
der geschäftsführer der firma auto
ticket schnee blatter am vormittag
ausgesagt dass er sich intensiv in die
verhandlungen eingebracht und am ende
sogar in einer so wörtlich
kurzschlussreaktion gekündigt haben die
unionsvertreter bleiben heute bei ihrer
linie
die zeugen zu diskreditieren und so ihre
glaubwürdigkeit in zweifel zu ziehen
[Musik]
wir können derzeit beides nicht
und dann gilt immer der grundsatz es
muss wissen wer es wird mit einer langen
nacht gerechnet wann der
verkehrsminister kommt scheint derzeit
offen
die koalition hat gestern überraschend
noch einen entlastungszeugen geladen
kesha container denn dann vor dem
ausschuss auftreten wird was glaubst du
wie wird seine taktik sein defensive
aggressiv umarmungsstrategie was ist von
dem auftritt von scheuer zu erwarten
also das ist natürlich ganz schwer zu
sagen
die unwahrscheinlichste variante ist
dass er heute hier auftritt und sagt
leute tut mir leid ich habe da letztes
jahr im bundestag wirklich unsinn
erzählt und ich habe noch mal drüber
nachgedacht und ja dieses angebot gab es
das wird vermutlich sage ich jetzt mal
nicht so kommen
er hat andere möglichkeiten er kann
natürlich auf seiner version bestehen
müsste er auch tun wenn er das nicht tun
würde müsste eben sagen ich habe den
bundestag belogen und dann steht hier
wirklich die frage im raum kann er als
minister noch weitermachen die spd hatte
schon angekündigt dass ihr das als
koalitionspartner dann nicht mittragen
kann und hat immer gesagt wir brauchen
einen nachweis dass er gelogen hat käme
er jetzt hier hin und würde plötzlich
eine andere version
hier vorstellen dann könnte man das
glaube ich als nachweis werten
er kann natürlich auch sagen naja nach
so langer zeit kann ich mich nicht mehr
ganz genau erinnern aber soweit ich mich
erinnern kann ist dieses angebot
durchgefallen
interessant war der heute übrigens auch
einigen fragen der union im
untersuchungsausschuss zuzuhören
verzeihung außerhalb war die war den
vertreterin der spd die die frage
gestellt hat die sagte nämlich kann es
denn sein dass dieses angebot den
vertrag ist nach dem urteil zu
unterschreiben so beiläufig gefallen ist
dass es nicht so richtig mitbekommen hat
und sich deswegen danach auch nicht
daran erinnern kann dass haben die
zeugen hier klar zurückgewiesen
der letzte zeuge gehört hatte herr cups
hat gesagt also ich vergess ja auch
schon mal das ein oder andere aber das
hätte ich nicht vergessen unter lauter
vielleicht viele zuschauer sich noch mal
vergegenwärtigen müssen wann was war wie
fing das eigentlich an mit der pkw maut
und was war dann mit dem gh und was kam
war
fassen wir gerade nochmal die recht
lange und unerfreuliche geschichte der
pkw-maut zusammen es war der wahlkampf
mit der csu bei der bundestagswahl 2013
eine pkw maut nur für ausländer
sie schafft es in den koalitionsvertrag
gegen den widerstand der kanzlerin
wir haben die pkw
doch die umsetzung dauerte unser
verkehrsminister dobrindt geschah nicht
viel erst sein nachfolger scheuer macht
nägel mit köpfen
im dezember 2018 schließt er einen zwei
milliarden vertrag mit zwei firmen ab
doch der hält nicht lange der
europäische gerichtshof stoppt das
projekt am 18 juni 2009 10
es sei so die richter nicht europa
konform einen persönlichen fehler sieht
heuer nicht ich habe den auftrag ein
projekt umzusetzen
das jetzt vom bgh gescheitert ist wie
man es dreht und wendet wenn ich dieses
projekt nicht umgesetzt hätte und es
wäre das urteil anders ausgegangen dann
wird diese forderungen auch geben
die verträge mit den beteiligten
unternehmen werden gekündigt für die
entgangenen einnahmen fordern sie
daraufhin schadensersatz in höhe von 560
millionen euro
die 560 millionen werden wir nicht
bezahlen nein bilanz lassen sich auch
mit solchen aussagen also das wird nicht
kommen
heuer wird wohl auch wegen des debakels
zum unbeliebtesten minister im frühjahr
dachte csu-chef söder laut über eine
kabinettsumbildung nach steuer wäre er
möglicherweise zum opfer gefallen wäre
nicht die korona krise dazwischen
gekommen darunter la wenn man sich das
anschaut und auch anschaut wie sich euer
verhalten hat dann ist tatsächlich nicht
anzunehmen dass er heute abend
eingestehen wird dass er fehler gemacht
hat denn das hat er ja über die ganze
phase hinweg auch nicht getan
davon würde ich tatsächlich ausgehen das
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass er das
heute hier tut auch wenn er wenn er
unter sehr großem druck steht
er weiß momentan noch die union in
seinem rücken die ihnen da unterstützt
und die hier auch immer wieder darauf
hinweist dass ja die zeugen die
ausgesagt haben auch interessengeleitet
sozusagen sind das bieterkonsortium war
hier ein stichwort was gefallen ist und
man muss tatsächlich auch sagen es gibt
noch ein paar fragen die man auch an die
zeugen stellen kann
da wird dazu gehört zum beispiel ein
gesprächsprotokoll was jetzt relativ
spät aufgetaucht ist über das eigentlich
umstrittene gespräch
die frage ging gab es oder gab es kein
angebot den vertrag auch nach dem
bgh-urteil zu unterschreiben dieses
gesprächsprotokoll ist so wie es jetzt
vorliegt wohl erst im september dieses
jahres erstellt worden und da kann man
natürlich schon die frage stellen warum
warum gab es das nicht vorher
es gibt auch die frage an das
ministerium warum gab es grundsätzlich
keine protokolle von diesen gesprächen
deswegen wird hier auch oft von
geheimgesprächen gesprochen weil es
normalerweise in solchen zusammenhängen
protokolle geben sollte aber momentan
weiß ich andreas scheuer noch
unterstützt von der union
denn das kippen würde dann wäre er
sicherlich gezwungen einen anderen weg
zu gehen und darüber einen rücktritt
nachzudenken
das fragt gerade einen user genau in
diese richtung der unimo 123 oder 100
123 auf youtube wie stark ist scheiders
rückhalt denn bei seinen parteikollegen
und gibt es da auch einen unterschied
zwischen cdu und csu
also diesen unterschied kann ich hier
heute nicht wahrnehmen man kann mal
vermuten dass der rückhalt in der csu
noch größer ist als in der cdu das ist
aber jetzt hier nach eine vermutung kann
ich heute hier so nicht ablesen
da waren vertreter von csu und cdu
gleich hart auch in der befragung der
zeugen auch das was die glaubwürdigkeit
angeht auch was den wissensstand angeht
es gab jetzt hier zuletzt eine szene die
wirkte sehr angespannt da haben cdu und
csu
den österreichischen betreiber vertreter
cups noch einmal befragt wie viele
eigentlich wissen konnte weil er am
anfang seiner aussage hier seiner
befragung die aussage gemacht hatte
das dass sie alle vollkommen überrascht
waren auch von der kündigung das ist
eine weitere frage die hier die hier
gesprochen wird
weil andreas scheuer damals gesagt hat
die betreiber hätten schlechte
leistungen erbracht
da gab es einige aussagen zu und da
haben cdu und csu sehr sehr stark
nachgefragt haben immer wieder versucht
klarzumachen dass der zeuge der da sitzt
eigentlich nicht so viel wissen kann wie
er vorgibt zu wissen
also da sehe ich keine trennlinie
zwischen cdu und csu
ich würde gern noch mal ein bisschen den
blick auf die institutionen
untersuchungsausschuss richten denn du
hast das wort kreuzverhör vorhin genannt
das war zeuge viel vorhin und bei
manchen könnte das vielleicht das gefühl
auslösen das ist so ein bisschen wie in
einem gerichtssaal die kollegin
christiane hübscher die auch im
hauptstadtstudio ist und sich auch mit
der maut sehr auseinander gesetzt hat
diesmal der sache nachgegangen was kann
der untersuchungs über
untersuchungsausschuss überhaupt und was
kann er nicht die wahrheit ist so ein u
ausschuss ist ein ziemlich zahnloser
tiger
klar der kann erst mal alle akten zur
sache anfordern
heuer hat ja dann auch die ersten 50
ordner persönlich mit dem handwagen in
den bundestag gefahren
das sind die verträge zur pkw maut
damit ist klar wir stehen bei allen
fragen zur pkw maut für maximal mögliche
transparenz mittlerweile sind das
zweieinhalb tausend ordner zur maut über
800.000 blatt papier um aufzuklären darf
der untersuchungsausschuss natürlich
auch zeugen befragen praktisch jeden aus
dem ministerium der mit der maut zu tun
hatte jeder referatsleiter aus dem
kanzleramt der dazu gange war
ehemalige verkehrsminister ehemalige csu
chefs das ist schon ein heißer stuhl
aber trotzdem darf man sich das nicht so
vorstellen dass da ein angeklagter sitzt
der macht ein geständnis und dann wird
irgendeine urteil des
das geht schon deshalb nicht weil es
nämlich gar keinen angeklagten gibt wer
eingeladen wird kommt als zeuge und ich
als angeklagte er ist zum erscheinen und
zur wahrheit verpflichtet
der schock und die wahrheit gibt es nur
eine oder werden wir am ende dieses uhr
ausschusses feststellen dass es da
verschiedene wahrheiten gibt
das ist die zentrale frage hier also
kann man eine wahrheit herausfinden
ich glaube dreh und angelpunkt wird die
frage sein wie verhält sich die spd die
immer gesagt hat wenn hier nachgewiesen
werden kann dass andreas scheuer gelogen
hat dann ist das für uns die rote linie
und dann käme also vom koalitionspartner
spd in der bundesregierung mit
sicherheit der die forderung dass
andreas scheuer zurücktreten muss wenn
man ihr der vertreterin frau die man
hier aber heute zugehört hat dann hat
man auch gemerkt
der wille ist schon da diese die diesen
klassiker zu folgen im zweifel für den
angeklagten
das heißt wenn es keine stichhaltigen
beweise gibt dafür dass er gelogen hat
dann kann man ihnen auch schlecht zum
rücktritt drängen
das ist das ist jetzt aktuell immer noch
die der stand der dinge und ob man jetzt
am ende wirklich eine wahrheit
herausfinden kann hier dass es wirklich
schwer zu sagen
nun ist du hast das angesprochen mit dem
rückhalt in der partei ja auch noch die
frage was markus söder am ende macht der
ja als csu-chef derjenige wäre zu
entscheiden ob der minister im amt
bleiben darf oder nicht und das alles
ist natürlich auch eine frage der
politischen verantwortung oder am ende
auch eine politische entscheidung was
glaubst du wie lange wird markus söder
der er vielleicht auch im hinterkopf hat
kanzlerkandidat zu werden hinter an die
scheuer stehen ja das ist die
entscheidende frage wenn es um den
rücktritt geht
denn wenn markus söder da sagen würde
jetzt jetzt reicht's jetzt geht es nicht
mehr
da auch dann wäre andreas scheuer zum
rücktritt gezwungen
markus söder hat bei uns im
zdf-sommerinterview gesagt dass scheider
der bekommt jetzt noch mal eine zweite
chance und meinte dass er sich dann auf
verschiedenen feldern beweisen kann er
hat auch gesagt es gibt ja noch den
untersuchungsausschuss und der wird die
sache klären ich glaube auch auf markus
söder wird der druck sehr wachsen wenn
diese untersuchungsausschuss mit dem
eindruck endet dass man hier zwar keine
wahrheit ermitteln kann das aber der
verkehrsminister auch nicht von von
jedem zweifel sozusagen befreit wurde
sondern dass ein sehr schwerer zweifel
noch an seiner aussage bleibt denn das
ist ja auch nicht das einzige problem
mit dem andreas scheuer gerade zu
kämpfen hat er hat auch noch
verschiedene andere andere krisen
sozusagen an der backe da ist die
autobahn reformen bei der ihm jetzt
rechtsverstöße vorgeworfen werden da ist
die verpatzte straßenverkehrsordnung für
die er auch die verantwortung trägt also
die frage ist dann irgendwann wie viele
fehler kann sich so ein minister
eigentlich leisten und dann trotzdem
noch im amt bleiben
und ja wenn markus söder ambitionen hat
und weiter im gespräch bleiben will dann
wird er sich das heute abend sehr genau
angucken wie das ausgeht und dann
möglicherweise seine schlüsse ziehen
ich würde gern noch die chance nutzen
eine user frage an dich zu stellen weil
das immer eine super möglichkeit ist den
korrespondenten die vor ort genauer
recherchieren und genau an den sachen
nah dran sind die die die möglichkeit
antworten zu geben und zwar fragt leon
kaiser über youtube er hat es aber klug
angestellt mit der aussage im bundestag
das war nicht thema in dem gespräch am
22 november er wird sagen das war teil
eines anderen gesprächs somit klug
gelogen was hat es damit auf sich kannst
du das erklären denn es fällt auf dass
mit den daten da irgendwas nicht stimmt
ja das stimmt das feld auf die frage
haben uns haben wir uns ja auch gestellt
und dann noch mal nachgeschaut er hat
tatsächlich da den 22 genannt das
verkehrsministerium hat das aber nachher
schriftlich richtig gestellt und hat
gesagt er meinte den 29 und damit ist er
also nicht aus dem schneider mit seiner
aussage war sein eigenes haus gesagt hat
nein er hat sich da nur vertan
in der woche und und gemeint war der
termin über den hier im
untersuchungsausschuss heute tatsächlich
auch gesprochen wird und ich glaube am
ende würde ist auf diese frage auch
nicht ankommen denn einen zahlendreher
oder einen kleinen irrtum den verzeiht
man jedem verkehrsminister aber das was
dahinter steht eine eine lüge in der
sache das wäre ein größeres problem
vielen dank und allah banerjee ich würde
dieses gespräch gerne beenden mit einem
user kommentar von emp schwester über
youtube hoffentlich darf er bleiben ohne
scheuer ist die heute show um einiges
unlustiger in diesem sinne sind wir sehr
gespannt was heute abend bei herauskommt
und danke dir für das gespräch
hinterland dankeschön nach berlin und
danke ihnen zu hause natürlich fürs
zuschauen machen sie es gut und eine
gute nacht kuss